welcome to this video playing inertia
master molten this is molten Lee let's
see how this is unknowns or spelled more
than Lee okay I've played him a couple
of times and he's usually very high
rated in the five-minute pool actually
one of his lower ratings okay the game
before I lost I really thought suspected
that my opponent in that game was
cheating but it wasn't entirely clear
but the whole game was played um yeah I
don't know when I saw the account
everything it looked very fishy and yeah
those kind of games are always very
awkward because you're right you feel
like they cheat you and you always you
play play weird sometimes anyway I
reported the guy we'll see what happens
but I really don't know what to make of
that game so I didn't upload that in at
all I felt it wasn't as clear as some
other cases and I really don't want to
yeah I mean I don't know what to do with
this kind of video so I didn't upload
okay this is a very typical situation
here out of them out of the the chicken
with this d take c5 move whiten opens up
the position and so yeah he's going for
this usually that doesn't lead to that
much like him defend this with with
pieces here okay um Nyjah form yeah i'm
just going to take that if it happens
yeah I can I think I can go back
or take on f5 that is not not a huge
problem normally hmm so moving the night
is a bit annoying okay I'm checking
let's doing it keep it keep it simple
approach yeah yeah I was thinking that
efore is a more you for which subjects
95 is probably an idea let's try it and
not think about it for ages getting I'm
getting to the 3m
93 is also interesting here immediately
getting this poll on d3 not sure about
this could be interesting okay if I
Teague and then 93 well that's also good
so it's going back to f1 Bishop c5 or is
he going have six or something huh now I
can take I can take f2 then right 9f to
a diff to as a threat now
that doesn't look too bad when I played
a lot also on earlier accounts the
pre-chat explained accounts and always
this very dangerous tactical plan so
have to be extra alert so I can check
and take be too if i like but also hmm
anything else what take between me at
night I think I'm taking here first it's
easier and now if I take be too he might
have that f6 business that feels very
irritating maybe just Quincy five
actually if it takes 95 this is a good
end game I get to a 4 or d3b to point is
just weak so if we trade screens I'm
happy with this end game i believe yep
doesn't trade queens so now it's also
possibly 95
maybe just f6 to stop stop this I'm not
sure it weakens a bit he possibly has
roped you one yep not sure how bad this
SS f6 idea fields did still feels very
dangerous if it happens maybe this
preventing this I'm not quite not quite
sure 94 I've gotten Queen F form between
b7 maybe you can do something like that
Luke t1 is also move pinning me
maybe i can probably maybe be four in
case of Ruby one but not too happy with
this loan it's taking a long time in k
Queen f4 was my idea
again I think the trade should be okay
and as root d2s coming through t 293 now
it's got be three maybe like would be 1
and B 3 Wow spending a long time so be
three I have 92 93 so I can still do
this okay and if I go 93 now be three I
can take F 2 mm not sure what it does or
if it does much time working
huh doesn't doesn't help too much I mean
it's not terrible but also not great any
good news now don't see it 95 said mo
don't see it trying for him some aging
net which not would that did not work
I'm not even attacking this this is bad
92 F or maybe check run Alfred bra
uh-huh yeah I know it's just another
good position and he's bought this
somehow from the from the time kind of
perspective mm yeah I think it shouldn't
shouldn't be too bad here this kind of
thing with night on d3 this this yeah
maybe I was too cautious i was always a
bit a bit afraid of this f6 resource so
I was kind of trying to keep that keep
that prevented yeah the engine wants to
take here and since I'm better but it's
easier easy easy I'm calculated by a
machine then played by a human I was
just a bit too afraid that this might
happen
91 now this is a very human move hmm
yeah well the Queen doesn't have a super
great scratchy Gocha Queen every it's
really tough I mean it's not very
realistic to play like this went here
and again I probably could have taken so
here I should be should be ok I think
with my active pieces but the way it was
played it didn't didn't look that great
93 be three okay look after is better ok
so here and now this ok add this is what
I missed this way I'm actually keeping
my head my porn them they're 60 x and
then should give some kind of line check
that leads to to a draw ultimately age
fire yeah I'm active enough I always
have this idea a Moose's night and he's
not easily winning in the porn so
probably a draw is the fair result of
the slide NTM getting getting a stray
somewhat know he could have [ __ ] mated
me here somehow check check check yeah
this is made checkmate mm-hmm okay I
know I could have taken taken at five
but again there was chick made check I
can I was just some hectic moves out for
the draw I mean again I feel we should
play increment chest and not this stuff
here we're now I would would be winning
by an or three seconds or something on
time so I offered to draw yeah I was too
cautious there probably should have
grabbed at be too at some point but I
have lost many many games where I'll
just take that material and then they
have
some kind of f6 counter-attack and I'm
losing at the end okay well thanks for
watching